why are you betting so big on content
why am I betting so so big on content so
first of all you know when you're saying
your content crew it didn't grow just
because you were creating content you
were creating good content right you
know people think just because they
create content they're going to get a
hit you're not it's got to be good
content you got to know which audience
you want to attract you have to figure
out a way to differentiate yourself it's
got to be less acting more you it's got
to be authentic either you're giving me
value you're making me laugh you're
making me aware you're steering the Pod
you're controversial you're doing
something to get attention and there's
many ways of doing it but today
uh uh you know years ago Steve Jobs when
he wanted to make a statement about what
Apple's doing he'd call Hugh Hefner from
Playboy magazine he'll say call your
editor-in-chief I want to talk to him he
would call him up and he would say I
want you to interview me I want you to
do is hit piece on me and this story but
he would call Playboy because that was
his audience okay Steve Jobs Playboy's
his audience that's what he would do
okay
today he doesn't have to do that today
he simply goes like James Corden right
James Corden goes to this restaurant in
New York and all of a sudden he has a
bad day two days ago three days ago and
it's horrible so this is two instances
where he disrespected the waiter waiter
and the waitresses it's the main
restaurant that everybody wants to go to
Balthazar or something like that right
what is the owner of the restaurant do
the owner of the restaurant doesn't call
New York Times or New York Post or L.A
times he goes on his Instagram account
he puts a picture of James Corden on the
bottom describes why he's 86th James
Corden why he's the only one of the only
few people he's 86 and 25 years and he
gives two stories of both times and he
says he can never come back to the
restaurant ever again well today
apparently James Corden called him last
night and had a conversation together
and he officially removed suspending him
and he cannot come back to the
restaurant because he profusely
apologized saying man I apologize for
what I did and they said okay no problem
you can come back to the restaurant so
if he wanted to do that before that
would have taken a longer life span
everything is content today everything's
messaging today speed is faster today
controlling the narrative is faster
today if 20 years ago I'm building a
business I'm probably more focused on
building the company brand than my brand
the difference between Jobs and Bill
Gates jobs understood his own brand
mattered as much as the company's brand
people didn't really see Bill Gates as a
brand people did see Steve Jobs as a
brand and you saw the similar thing with
Larry Ellison and some of these other
guys and today you know you're seeing
the difference between Bezos and Musk
Bezos at one point was worth more but
people don't know Bezos they don't even
like Bezos why don't they like Bezos why
don't people like them because no one
knows nothing about the guy why do
people like the Elon Musk why do people
like this guy he's louder than basil
shouldn't they not like Elon Musk well
then Elon Musk trained Bezos to realize
hey Bezos you got to get a little bit
more vocal you got to start paying
attention to your brand so what does the
Bezos do Bezos starts showing what he's
doing traveling having fun he posts a
picture with his muscles saying hey come
on Leo say something to my girl in a
joking way then he calls out Joe Biden
because Elon Musk is so vocal about what
he's saying now people are saying hey
his engagement's gone up people are
liking Bezos there's a little bit of
this guy's got guts he's got audacity so
everyone's starting to realize you know
in today's era whether you like it or
not we're all naked there used to be a
time we could all just hide and be quiet
it's not an effective strategy today
because today when somebody doesn't say
anything about anything we see them as
ingenuous when somebody doesn't have an
opinion about things we see them as
they're hiding something versus here's
how I feel about this here's how I feel
about that here's how I feel about this
people are trusting brains more who's a
leader at the top has a position not
necessarily A you know black and white
position but we know you a little bit
versus we know nothing about you because
we don't know whether we should trust
you or not if you enjoyed this content
and want to take your YouTube channel to
the next level just click or tap the
link on the screen or go to
tube1kchallenge.com to join our next
live YouTube challenge you'll learn our
best tips and strategies that are
working here at think media and I think
you'll love it